you're not gonna believe who the Winter
Soldier is it's a big surprise twist
unless you have internet or friends
Captain America the Winter Soldier this
movie was incredible
like the Hulk I referenced the Marvel
movie this is without a doubt one of
Marvel's best movies ever it's right up
there daredevil Fantastic Four and all
three Punisher movies from kidding
please don't send me death threats it's
like a spy espionage thriller I love
that I remember that type of genre if
you're gonna throw Captain America in
the modern-day world it's like why not
go for spy conspiracy thriller type of
feel instead of just having to be a
soldier again by the way it's product
Wow yeah
on the minder we're because it's the
only Avengers thing I own that's much
more serious tone than any other recent
Marvel films and it totally works for
this story because you know the best
solution is to go darker the writing and
directing is fantastic it's
pulse-pounding suspense smart twists
here in there like the reveal of the
Winter Soldier there's just enough humor
just enough it feels like its own
standalone movie unlike the first one
that sort of just felt like a big setup
for the Avengers I know some of you guys
are gonna hate me for saying that from
beginning to end the whole time you're
just captain hooked the plot
consistently escalates it has great
character moments it's intense it's just
so damn good now right off the bat Chris
Evans that's the same as Captain America
Steve Rogers he's the captain of America
I love them way more in this film in the
first one and even the Avengers it feels
more relatable he's 10 times weren't
treating and compelling to watch as he's
darker Chris Evans could just step into
this role like nobody's business and he
just gets buffer every movie his arms
are so damn sexy I want to hold his arms
and then feel it flex which would
probably send me flying off into this
sky he's worth of badass Captain America
I wanted a watch when I saw the first
one it was the first time I walked out
of a movie featuring him where I was
like I wanna be this guy he's so cool
you guys know that feeling I'm talking
about right when you walked out of a
theater and you feel like you're the
main character yeah I walk out of the
theater I just kicked a bunch of
people's asses it's totally worth it oh
and I remember Jeremy Jones talking
about cap shield the comp cap because
you know we're buddies and he was right
his
use of this shield in this one it's ten
times more badass it feels like an
extension of Captain America you wish
you had that boomerang shield so you can
throw it at people who piss you off like
a mother [ __ ] take one of your french
fries without asking Scarlett Johansson
as Black Widow best ass in the world I
would chew up that ass I like her ass
she deserves a non standalone film
there's more focus on her character than
ever
she's not a distraction in this film
she's great to have in this movie super
sexy super badass man that ass thats
performance we've got enough this
character yet Anthony Mackie as falco
punch as Falcon he's Captain America's
new black friend it's like the Roger
Murtagh - the Martin Riggs
he's like Eddie Murphy - Nick Nolte is
like Chris Tucker - Jackie Chan who's
not white but don't get me wrong he
didn't play like a black guy I mean he
is black but you know what I mean who's
just this awesome soldier he's really
funny in the film adds humor to it very
charming total badass this [ __ ]
can't kick some serious ass what he's
zipping around the sky samuel l.jackson
as Nick Ferry it's the worst Samuel
Jackson impression ever the Explorer
Nick Fury more than they ever have you
feel like you understand them way more
by the end of this film he also gets to
kick ass in this film there's just one
car chase sequence that's led by am so
damn good just some of this that's Nick
Fury performance we've got him yet he
mentioned blowing Samuel Jackson you'd
be yelling at you the whole time I want
you to suck [ __ ] seriously where's
Samuel Jackson pressure never Robert
Redford as something Pierce
he's what you call a natural where it
doesn't seem like he's doing much they
may look back on the phone you're like
that was a great [ __ ] performance I
loved his freckles and of course the
action in the visuals the action is not
just cool to watch the action scenes are
spread apart they're not it's not like
non-stop throughout and when the action
sequences come in they come in at the
exact right time where there's actual
suspense in the action you're like
emotionally invested your heart starts
beating you believe main characters can
die as far as Captain America black
widow go for the action
they just amp them up so much I just
think Scarlett Johansson says there's
gunfights there's martial arts fights
that's right Captain America I've
learned his [ __ ] - the martial arts
along the way now this isn't really a
complaint but the Winter Soldier doesn't
really have much focus in the film he's
not in the movie that much I mean is he
cool yeah he's cool piece of villainous
sometimes a little scary but overall not
entire
sure why it's called a Winter Soldier
maybe it's referring to more than just
the Winter Soldier character because
there's a much bigger plot this film is
focused on than just the bad guy so if
you're going into this movie mainly
because you want to see the Winter
Soldier kick ass you're probably gonna
be disappointed but if you're going into
it because you just want to see a damn
good film and take this movie on this
own merits you're in for one hell of a
show my friends is this film is an IMAX
experience yes sir we just had me all
giddy I want to be in an action movie
one day well let me get straight to the
point here oh and all I got to see
Captain America the Winter Soldier got
it super duper Ryan right all right guys
there's checking on my review for
Captain America the Winter Soldier
what should co-head skull that comment
box below and tell me which celebrity do
you think has the best ass and if you
want to see more episodes a straight to
the point
I want throw out there we're gonna be
releasing a spoiler review of Captain
America the Winter Soldier GRE and I he
just released his first impressions he
does videos and him come on the car
after he's done watching a movie it's
really cool [ __ ] I never heard Jerry
[ __ ] before last but not least you're
gonna get updated every time one of my
reviews or videos is out going to click
on this but about my dick to subscribe
that's right the dick let me say
something bout this little soldier he
bangs all kinds of chicks during the
winter that's right he's the captain of
America bone all kinds of American woman
then after my rate review he's hoping to
bone some Indonesian chicks